y
[Música]
estampida mortal en israel al menos 44
personas murieron aplastadas cuando
alrededor de 100.000 judíos
ultraortodoxos celebraban la popular
fiesta religiosa del acv a omer con
cánticos bailes y hogueras en el monte
melón de galilea se supone uno de los
incidentes más trágicos en la historia
reciente del país
francia se prepara para la reapertura de
comercios no esenciales a pesar de
haberse detectado los primeros casos de
la variante india conocida como de doble
mutación en el territorio ya se
conocieron los detalles de un plan de
cuatro etapas del gobierno de manuel
macro que irá del 3 de mayo al 30 de
junio se los damos a conocer
y también en francia se le realizó un
homenaje póstumo al oficial de policía
éste panismo en fernet asesinada a
puñaladas en la semana pasada en una
comisaría el ataque fue perpetrado por
un ciudadano tunecino que poco después
murió en un enfrentamiento con la
policía el primer ministro jan castex
aseguró que conforme fue víctima de
terrorismo islamista
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france24 blanco como siempre
un gusto saludarlos comenzamos en israel
donde una gigantesca estampida dejado al
menos 44 personas muertas decenas de
miles de personas asistieron al festival
religioso el trabajo en melón en el
norte del país el evento fue una de las
mayores concentraciones en israel desde
el estallido de la pandemia de
coronavirus hace más de un año veamos el
siguiente informe
estas ambulancias llegan para
transportar las últimas bolsas de
cadáveres la policía ha acordonado la
zona y está supervisando la operación en
cooperación con el mando del frente
interno y con el servicio paramédico
llevamos a cabo una compleja y amplio
actuación de los heridos a los
hospitales tanto en vehículos como en
helicópteros ok
a este hospital los heridos llegan por
docenas
asistentes relatan escenas de pánico en
las que personas murieron delante de sus
ojos
era como ser arrastrada en un carrusel
una persona empujaba a otra venía de
todos lados entonces la gente empezó a
ahogarse y quería salir pero era
imposible
las imágenes aficionadas muestran a la
multitud empujándose en un espacio
estrecho los testigos dicen que la
estampida comenzó en la sección
masculina del festival se creado por
sexos el primer ministro benjamin
netanyahu visitó el lugar y habló en
twitter de un grave desastre la
peregrinación tuvo lugar al margen de la
festividad anual judía de lac baumer en
la tumba del siglo 2 del rabino bar
lucha y marcaba el fin de una
devastadora epidemia en el país siendo
el mayor evento festivo desde el inicio
de la pandemia en un país casi
completamente desconfiado las
autoridades habían permitido la entrada
de 10.000 personas pero según la prensa
local no se respetó el aforo en 2019 los
organizadores habían estimado que 200
a mil peregrinos habrían acudido al
lugar
y cambiamos ahora información porque se
conocieron los detalles del plan de
gobierno francés para la reapertura del
país en cuatro etapas se reabrirán
progresivamente las escuelas de
secundaria a los cines museos y las
terrazas de los restaurantes todo
dependiendo por supuesto del
comportamiento de la pandemia en el país
y tras descubrirse los primeros casos de
la variante india en el territorio galo
el presidente manuel macrón anunció que
la vacunación a todos los mayores de 18
años comenzará el 15 de junio desde
parís se dedicó a la barrilla con todos
los detalles de este plan
los franceses comienzan a ver la luz al
final del túnel de este tercer
confinamiento después de haber escuchado
esta noche de los anuncios que el
presidente emmanuel macrón hizo a la
prensa regional para detallar su plan
progresivo de confinamiento de este país
en cuatro etapas la primera de ellas
comienza el próximo lunes cuando se
vuelven a autorizar los viajes entre
regiones la segunda etapa está fijada
para el 19 de mayo
ese día se retrasa en dos horas el
inicio del toque de queda de las siete a
las nueve de la noche por lo que es más
importante abre nuevamente bares y
restaurantes en terraza y también los
sitios culturales incluso los cines los
sitios que acogen actividades deportivas
y los comercios siempre con un aforo
limitado la tercera etapa está fijada
para el 9 de junio a partir de ese día
abren bares y restaurantes en sala se
atrasa nuevamente en dos horas el toque
de queda a las once de la noche y lo que
es más importante se pone en práctica el
paseo sanitario ese certificado donde se
sabe si tenemos o no las vacunas contra
el cob y ya hemos tenido la enfermedad
después de más de 15 días si tenemos un
psr negativo será importante pues con
ese certificado se podrá asistir a
partir de
a fecha a eventos de más de 5000
personas y finalmente la última etapa es
el 30 de junio a partir de ese día ya no
habrá más toques de queda pero ojo el
presidente no dijo nada sobre las
discotecas que siguen cerradas dice que
sigue privilegiando el trabajo a
distancia y también siguen siendo
obligatorios los gestos barrera pero
este calendario depende de un dato la
cifra de incidencia del cob y 19 esto es
el número de casos por cada 100.000
habitantes si los datos no son buenos
este calendario no se mantiene y
seguimos en francia donde el primer
ministro jan castex se rindió homenaje
en una ceremonia televisada a nivel
nacional el oficial de policía
administrativa asesinada a puñaladas la
semana pasada en una comisaría
stephanie me enfermé una madre de tres
hijos de 49 años fue atacada por un
ciudadano tunecino que luego murió a
manos de la policía
en la ceremonia castex se otorgó
póstumamente am 11 ml medalla la
elección de honor
[Música]
el pasado viernes poco después de las
dos de la tarde stephanie monjes acababa
de retomar sus servicios el servicio de
sus conciudadanos cuando un hombre
apareció de la nada para asesinarla con
un salvajismo y una determinación
espantosa en determinación que fue un
genio
busco porque este odio de un hombre
hacia una mujer que no conocía una mujer
que no le había hecho nada una mujer que
no tenía nada que ver con sus
resentimientos porque hacia el santísimo
poco
y bien para otro colega en carnes y
bueno porque vuestra colega encarnaba a
los ojos de ese hombre cuyo nombre me
rehúso a pronunciar a la policía
francesa y por tanto a la autoridad del
estado de delito en otras noticias la
situación en india por cuenta de la
pandemia sigue siendo crítica la nación
registró en las últimas 24 horas 380 mil
nuevos casos y tres mil 645 muertos un
avión militar estadounidense llevó este
jueves la primera ayuda médica de
emergencia más de 400 cilindros de
oxígeno entre otros equipos
hospitalarios y cerca de un millón de
tests rápidos de coronal y 2
los glaciares se derriten a ritmo
acelerado en casi todo el mundo un
estudio publicado por la revista
'nature' muestra los patrones del cielo
en las regiones como los alpes en el
norte del atlántico oa las casas rojas
con los detalles
una placa en honor a un glaciar que ya
no existe a las generaciones futuras
aquí existió el glaciar a lo loco y
retrocedió hasta desaparecer en 2018
en las próximas décadas los glaseadas
mexicanos desaparecerán
irremediablemente según un reciente
estudio de la revista nation miles de
glaciares en el mundo podrán correr la
misma suerte con imágenes satelitales
estudiaron alrededor de 220.000
glaciares del mundo excluyendo los de
groenlandia y la antártica desde 2000
hasta 2019 su conclusión es que estas
capas de hielo se están derritiendo
rápidamente alterando el nivel del mar y
los ecosistemas en múltiples dimensiones
name la verdad
a escala global el principal causante es
la temperatura
y es difícil de separar el hecho de que
la temperatura está causando el deshielo
con el hecho de que los humanos están
por mucho causando el incremento de la
temperatura
jose
durante el periodo estudiado los
glaciares perdieron un promedio de 267
giga toneladas de hielo al año la nasa
calcula que sólo una gigatonelada de
hielo equivaldría a un bloque de 341
metros de altura sobre el central park
de nueva york
una vez se derrite es casi imposible
recuperar un glaciar se requieren
décadas o siglos para acumular las
lluvias de un año tras otro y contar con
las temperaturas óptimas para que esa
agua se congele así que no estamos en un
punto donde la discusión se acerca de
hacer crecer los glaciares o mantenerlos
exactamente que están ahora estamos en
un punto en el que estamos tratando de
mantener tanto hielo como sea posible y
realmente disminuir la tasa de pérdida
en un estudio similar que sintetizó más
de 100 modelos por computadora generados
por institutos de todo el mundo el
diario británico the gardian concluyó
que un 10 por ciento del hielo glaciar
se perderá de aquí a 2050 incluso si se
cumplen los objetivos del acuerdo de
parís
y de esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo en france24 buen día para
todos
[Música]
france24 en español sigue creciendo